there's a very good reason why the role
of Freddie Wong scared the hell out of
kihi Kwan he almost didn't take part at
all and Michelle yo had to be extremely
careful to be respectful in her fight
scenes you've seen the magic but today
we're going to break down everything
that went into making american-born
Chinese
you may have loved Freddie Wong as the
true hero of american-born Chinese he
didn't get quite as many cool scenes as
some of the other characters which we'll
be breaking down in more detail soon but
he still tackled Asian stereotypes
head-on which was the reason why Kwan
actually passed on the role when he was
first approached about it he worried
that this is the type of portrayal that
we don't want to see in 2023 it wasn't
until he had a conversation with the
creative team that he realized you'd
actually get to meet the actor who plays
Freddie Wong and gain a better
understanding of his struggle playing an
Asian stereotype on Beyond repair Juan
thought this was very interesting and
felt like being able to play a character
like this was a bit like art imitating
life I just wanted to be someone who
goes on the journey american-born
Chinese is packed with action still
images were taken from the graphic novel
and reimagined as fully choreographed
fight scenes they were trying to make
the fight feel very authentic to Asian
Cinema and the Hong Kong style
particularly I mean you're going to see
crazy cool Hong Kong wire work many of
the stunt coordinators actually came
from China and these people are as close
to real life superheroes as you've ever
met part of the Hong Kong style involves
making the camera part of the stunt work
meaning that the camera is in there
moving along with everybody and the
takes would often be longer it's so
beautifully choreographed you want to
see it all as we're sure you can imagine
it's not easy to do and can be very
tiring for the cameramen when it came to
Michelle Yao's stunt work however things
were done a little differently Michelle
yo plays Guan Yin the goddess of mercy
and Michelle knew that if she was going
to fill such big shoes then she needed
to be very respectful she says that the
goddess of Mercy does not fight she
looks at you with love and compassion
and so when it came time for her big
Showdown against Wu's gold demon Guan
Yin fought back but the choreographers
made sure to Stage it all so that she
doesn't hit him or punch him ever
Michelle explained that Guan Yin
deflecting him she's pushed pushing him
away and that the entire time she needs
to teach him a lesson or hopes that she
can impart a lesson on him that's pretty
impressive and if you think so too then
we're definitely recommending hitting
that subscribe button but she wasn't
even the only famous figure from Chinese
culture in the series are you familiar
with Journey to the West if you need a
refresher it's a classic of Chinese
literature that follows the
fictionalized account of a Buddhist
Monk's journey to India in the 7th
Century it's been adapted into several
movies of its own and many of the
mythological figures from american-born
Chinese are brought straight out of
Journey to the West like The Monkey King
whose staff will be discussing very soon
and of course Michelle's character is
described as being from heaven now part
of Earth Michelle was very happy with
the way that our writers have brought
her to a very modern place but above all
she was grateful for the chance to be
able to tell these stories for friends
over here that might not know especially
considering how widely beloved Journey
to the West is in China epic
consequences for those of you familiar
with Sun Wukong this is a version of him
like you've never seen before because
he's like a father and he's like got
responsibilities The Monkey King Staff
plays a huge role in the show when it's
stolen by his son and the props
Department had a pretty big task on
their hands if they wanted to get its
size changing abilities right multiple
versions of the staff were built in
different sizes so that they could be
switched out between takes Jim Liu had
three weeks of stunt training just to
learn how to use the staff and he admits
it was pretty hard his hands would hurt
afterwards because of how heavy the prop
was but he was happy with the results at
the end of the day plus it wasn't all
just work in training before filming
began do you have any special rituals
Michelle yo does before a production she
likes to gather together everyone from
the cast and crew and join them in a
blessing ceremony she clarifies that
it's not a religious ceremony the way
she describes it it's like give us your
blessings let us work here peacefully
bless everyone who is on the project and
we will not disturb you too much this is
something that Michelle got very used to
doing working on Productions in Hong
Kong since then she's taken this ritual
to the set of american-born Chinese and
everything everywhere all at once and
everyone got pretty into it Marvin Marr
took to Instagram with the picture of
the cast celebrating a blessing ceremony
for a blessed show that it sure was and
the characters had to look the part
costume designer Joy didn't grow
up with Journey to the West like many of
the cast and crew did she had to rely on
Sally Wu another costume designer to
pass along the stories she'd heard from
her grandmother growing up so that the
costumes could take influence from
tradition we definitely pulled from
Traditions but adding a new Fresh take
on her as much as they wanted the
characters to feel familiar to the
audience they also wanted to give us a
fresh High fashion take on these beloved
characters like a Couture fashion show
the reward for most complicated makeup
might have to go to Daniel Wu's Heaven
Monkey King which included being done up
in full monkey Prosthetics in a process
that took around three hours I just see
a monkey in the mirror so it's pretty
cool it was going to take a very special
team to be able to get a story like this
right but you can really tell that
everybody involved in the project cared
a whole lot about it were you surprised
to hear that kihi Kwan originally passed
on the show or was there another behind
the scenes detail that you found more
shocking make sure to let us know what
you think down in the comments section